[Music]
don't forget to enter our amazon gift
card giveaway all you have to do is be a
subscriber like and comment
hey guys the upcoming 5th episode is the
final big battle episode of the show
this episode is where the things will
actually go down even the last war of
kings landing for the iron throne will
be completed
obviously many characters are going to
die in this episode and that's what we
are going to talk about in this video
we are bringing you characters that are
most definitely going to die tonight
starting with jaime and cersei lannister
jaime and search say will die together
this has been heavily foreshadowed
throughout the entire series not only tv
series
but the book series as well the lanester
twinsfield died together much like they
were born together
and spend their lives together in a
feast for crowd cersei says this about
her and jaime
we will leave this world together as we
once came into it
in a storm of sorts jaime says this i
cannot die while cersei lives
we will die together as we were born
together in a dance to dragons cersei
says this about jaime to her uncle
if he were dead i would know it we came
into this world together uncle
he would not go without me in season 5
episode 4
jaime told braun that he'd like to die
in the hands of a woman he loves
and even elena for shadow of cersei will
eventually be the end of jaime
alena said to him you poor fool you love
her she'll be the end of you
and jaime responded with possibly jaime
and cersei will die together in
tonight's episode
jaime will arrive at king's landing
early on in the episode and here in this
shot you can see a hooded man passing
through the golden company
as they march out of king's landing to
face the upcoming danish forces
that who did manage jaime lannister it's
the same cloak and hood he had been
arriving in winterfell
and now he's got it and arriving at
king's landing while the golden company
marches outside red keep james heading
towards it to face
cersei at the end of episode 4 sir set
shows violence over negotiations
and killed one of dany's best friends
and most loyal advisors
it was a perfect way to set up the hype
and thirst of engines for us the viewers
but also for dany search evoked the
dragon
and she will suffer the consequences in
episode 5 fire and blood
danny has lost almost everything and if
cersei thinks she is safe just because
she invited citizens inside the red keep
she is up for a big surprise as
missandei's last words said jakartas
i can guarantee you denny and the
unsullied will go on an execution spree
in king's landing
they will only show the heavens cersei
but unfortunately i think that will be
exactly what cersei wanted
if cersei did not want danny to attack
king's laning and the red key but rather
wanted to end the war some other way
cersei would not have beheaded missandei
cersei wants dany to attack
and it's all part of her plan to end
dany in her poetic justice way
i think cersei has worked out this
entire plane in her head and we will not
watch it play out
perhaps she wants dany to unleash drogon
and start burning king's landing
bringing sir's opportunity to use many
qyburn scorpions to bring down her last
dragon
and then use the golden company lane
inserts and euros forces to deal with
the remains of denis forces
or perhaps she intends to get them all
fighting inside the capital
and then burn them all with wildfire or
even more possibly cersei knows her
reign is over
but she will not just accept it she is
going to pull dany with her
cersei worked hard on appearing in his
landing and made the small folks see
dany as a conqueror
rather than a liberator the army of the
dead is a myth for them a lie
cersei also invited all the small folk
to hide behind their walls earning their
loyalty
when in reality she's inviting them
inside to use them as a shield from dany
and her dragons
now dany is left with no choice but to
kill cersei which will unfortunately
take many small folk lives along
she tried to negotiate she tried
everything and all she has got in return
was losing almost everyone she cares
about then is going to burn neon's plate
in episode 5.
dragon will avenge his fallen brother
and euron is not resistant to jungle
fire as the night king was
but iron and his fleet will not be the
only thing that's going down burning
most of king's laning will as well
search states hiding inside red keep and
get herself surrounded by the small folk
dennis got no choice but to burn the red
keep even if it means many innocent
people will die along
and she will in episode 5 as leaked
photos seem to be confirming
and unfortunately i think it's all part
of cersei's plan
she knows she loves game of thrones and
when you play this game you win or you
die
she knows she cannot win this war but
she can make look danny like the mad
queen
by making her burn all the innocent if
she wants to burn her as well
one way or another cersei's face
expression she gives dany after killing
miss sandy is basically telling that
that's exactly the reaction she wanted
from dany
to unleash fire and blood on the capital
i'm a bit upset
knowing that after this manny will
declare danny the mad queen
which is definitely not and john will
then have to kill her to protect the
realm
in my opinion even if she ends up
burning the entire king's landing it's
justified
she tried absolutely everything to avoid
it she did not want to do it back in
season 7
when she thought there might be some
other better solution to avoid many
civilian casualties
but now there really is none danny has
to kill her enemies
and that does not make her the mad queen
aegon the conqueror burned many castles
to the ground
ended up many houses which of course
killed many innocent people along
as it usually goes to it every more but
you don't see people calling him the mad
king
leaked photos confirmed that many parts
of king's landing will indeed be burned
down by dragonfire
for the final season of game of thrones
reproduction for the very first time
instead of filming king's landing scene
scene drew browning
they decided to make a huge game's
laning set in belfast and film most of
the scenes there
all king's laning shots saw in episode 4
were filmed on that set
it's not a real city it's a huge
enormous set
the reason they built that set is so
they can burn it down
that's the reason they had to build this
huge set rather than film all the scenes
in jabronic
however as you can see in these leaked
photos the set was later burned down
with a huge bridge between demolish
towers
danny using drogon has seemingly burned
down huge portions of the capital
including his landing dome it's a
well-known fact that the show built a
king's landing set mainly to do live
prior technics
it means that some parts of the capital
will be burned down by a dragon
as dragon fire in game of thrones is
portrayed by live pyrotechnics
tennis dragon that is responsible for a
huge portion of the capital being burned
down was spotted on this king's landing
set
what this means is that dany will
probably land at king's landing either
because jorgen is mortally wounded and
cannot fly anymore or she decides to
land after she's burned everything down
in case you're not really into filming
and behind the scenes clips
let me remind you that if actors have to
mount or dismount a dragon
part of its spine has to be physically
recreated which is exactly what his
massive contraption on king's landing
set
is this massive conception being on this
very same set means that danny will at
some point decide to land in king's
landing
we have all known that juggles would
eventually fly over king's landing
as bran saw it in his vision of the
future and we now know for a fact it's
dany riding shogun
just the moments before she unleashes
her vengeance on the red keep
speaking of bran's visions from the
future that are yet to come true we also
have this fun of the destroyed throne
room covered in ashes
let me remind you that while prophecies
in game of thrones don't literally come
true visions on the other hand do
all bran's visions already came true
including modifier attacks cersei used
on the septobalar and the only two
visions that are yet to come through a
vision of a shadow flying above the
capital
and the red keep destroyed they'll both
come true in tonight's episode
supportive in leaked photos the follow
king's laning is confirmed
then he will burn down the red keep
killing cersei and finally ending her
reign
then he will end up killing many
innocent people along but dany really
doesn't have a choice
if she wants her say dead she's got to
kill the innocent people cersei invited
inside to act as her shield
or even more possibly her post-death
master plan to destroy dany
danny will burn down euron's fleet and
the red keep killing cersei
but also most likely killing jaime as
well who will probably be with cersei
the lancer twins came to this world
together and they will now live together
unfortunately after dany kills her says
she will then face cersei's special plan
cersei's poetic justice cersei knew
danny would win this war
and that's why she invited all the small
folk to die alongside her
so the daniels had to kill all the
innocent people to get her to ensure
that dany appears to be no better than
her father
but she lose her trust of her army and
her closest advisors
when you play the game of thrones steven
or you die she lost and she died
but she made sure daeny would seem like
the mad queen that's her final move
jon will kill dany because of it
although not in episode 5
but in the final episode i think
throughout the entire episode v
all these different people all denny's
loyal advisors will start telling jon
how dan is becoming much like her father
wanting to burn the entire king's
landing and all the innocent people
everything to kill cersei and become the
queen
jon will tell dany that varys is
conspiring behind her back
and then he will burn him alive then
later danny will burn down the red keep
killing stars saying jaime
but also a bunch of innocent people and
that's when tyrion will probably decide
that varys was right after all
and that's when tyrion will tell jon
that dany is the mad queen and they need
to stop her
at the end after king's landing has been
burned down and many innocent people
have died
i can see jon killing dany so long story
short dany finally gets to kill cersei
and jaime
and she wins the armed mountain but she
will not be able to sit on it because
jon will have to kill her
convinced that she's become her father's
daughter and she'll join drogo and her
son on the other world
fulfilling cersei's poetic justice plan
for dany
before dany burns downward keep the
hound in the mountain will also fight
and even though i think the hound will
have the upper hand i think both
brothers will die
as i mentioned earlier in this video
verse will also die in episode 5.
this was heavily hinted and foreshadowed
to happen tonight
first of mel sanchez prophesied he will
die even though melisandre speaks truth
maris has also betrayed daniel's sided
with jon snow and then he will have to
execute him for that
danny did warn him that if he ever sees
another person is more fit to rule than
she is
to tell her that in her face and not to
plot or throw her behind her back
or otherwise she'd burn him alive and
what did varys do after hearing john is
a targaryen
he immediately started plotting behind
her back i do not believe tyrion is
going to tell daniel varys betrayal
i think jon will in this chat from
episode 5 john arrives at genostone
and luke was there to greet him and have
a little chat bears
i think varys will say to john that he
knows he's a targaryen
and that he would make a far better
ruler than dany
john would obviously reply to that with
denny's my queen what you're telling me
is a treason
so verse tells jon jon tells dany about
how she was right
he shouldn't have told anyone and now
varys is already plotting to put him on
the arm throne
then he will then burn very salive i
believe here dany commands grey worm to
find and bring her varies to execute him
for a treason
and this is a shot of tyrion concerned
and worried
okay guys that will be all the major
deaths that will most definitely happen
in tonight's episode
please let me know your thoughts about
all of this in the comment section down
below
and as always i hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our channel and i hope
to see you in the next one
peace